the new Star Trek series Starfleet
Academy has been green lit but why
welcome to science Trek your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel
[Music]
so this is a plan that has been bouncing
around for literally decades the
Paramount have wanted to make a series
or potentially a movie based around
Starfleet Academy now I keep calling
this series Star Trek 90210 because it's
going to be filled with a bunch of
teenagers or actors pretended to be
teenagers in the case of 90210 and it's
just going to be all teenage angst and
bloody I don't know what but is there a
possibility this could be actually a TV
series that we'd want to watch spoiler
probably not so I've actually spoken to
the podcast guys about this and one of
them told me that actually this has been
in the bag definite for about six months
but a lot of the sources I've spoken to
said actually that's probably not the
case even though this might have been
agreed with secret hideout six months
ago there have been a lot of internal
voices that have been saying maybe we
shouldn't go this direction I've Heard
lots and lots of rumors coming out of
Paramount that actually they don't want
to go in this direction now in some ways
I think that really isn't a surprise if
everybody body agreed that really would
be a shock and not all the trekkies out
there are the biggest fans of Alex
kurdzman I myself have actually Fallen
foul of people with bits of information
who are genuine sources but do have
agendas against Alex gertzman that they
really do not want him anywhere near our
Star Trek and they would really do
anything to get him away from it now
they hear bits of information rumors
like I hear and they put that
perspective on it their agenda and they
assume it means that Alex kurtzman is on
his way out now we've all heard the
rumors over and over again that Alex
Goodson is going to get fired where we
forget actually that Alex Kirsten
doesn't work for Palmer who works for
completely secret hideout the production
company so we really can't get fired not
by Paramount anyway but what they could
do and what Paramount apparently were
genuinely seriously considering only a
few weeks ago even about moving Star
Trek away from secret hideout this is
one of the rumors we've heard a few
times now that actually a lot of the TV
shows that secret already got did they
were spreading them out a little bit and
they were moving towards being able to
end the contract with secret hideout and
move to somebody else then out of
nowhere really and against a lot of the
tide of a lot of the information I've
been getting suddenly Alex kurtzman and
secret hideout get a new live-action
Star Trek series Starfleet Academy now
this was a shock and I have to admit One
Source I speak to actually works for
quite a large agency in Hollywood and he
said this actually genuinely surprised
them that genuinely the rumors that were
coming around was that actually secret
hideout were possibly not on their way
out of Paramount but were possibly not
going to be getting Star Trek and if
they were going to be getting another
Star Trek series it would be only one
not two or three
but with Starfleet Academy replacing
discovery that does make it look like
actually Paramount are running up to
maybe doing this as well as maybe
something also to replace Picard
so keeping the current five seasons of
Television we've become used to
so if that is the case and all of the
rumors about people at Paramount not
being particularly happy with secret
hideout are also true
then what has happened well now there's
another rumor saying that actually
somehow Alex curtisman has got Michelle
you know to do section 31 and
particularly following her Oscar win
Paramount got very interested in doing
section 31 and Alex kurtman was able to
use that to get starfully Academy that
he wanted
there's also a rumor that the reason why
Starfleet Academy is being co-show run
by Alex kurtzman and nogalando is
because that was the Compromise the
Paramount came up with they said look if
you want to do this that's fine but
we're bringing somebody else in to help
you because we're not happy with some of
the creative decisions you've made in
the past now certainly that's not how
they framed that conversation but that
is the rumor I've heard now
if everybody within the company of
Paramount was agreeing and on the same
page with this I would be more surprised
than if they weren't so the fact that we
hear rumors about certain aspects of
parliament certain Executives not being
very happy with sickai that really
shouldn't surprise us but also there is
really two camps within the trekki
community there's the very anti-alex
kurtzman camp and there's the side of
things I actually quite like the new
track and are quite Pro kurtzmann in his
team
so when a piece of information comes out
that information can be twisted really
either way by either side what does seem
to be true and this has come from
reliable sources is as I say Paramount
have not been particularly happy with
secret either and that this current deal
was a compromise but are actually
there's some positives about the
possible staffly Academy show well for
one Discovery is set in the 32nd century
and that's quite exciting I like the
prospect of exploring the future a
little further following the burn that
happened halfway through Discovery this
stupid wave that ended up all of the
dilithium within the Federation has
exploded I don't know why the romulans
didn't just come in and take over
because they don't use their lithium in
their course so surely they should be
the most dominant power in the alpha
quadrant but I don't think we've seen
them in Discovery but I will admit I
stopped watching discovering season four
I got so bored of it and I absolutely
loved Star Trek and strange new worlds
and I loved season three of Picard but
I'm one of those people I have no agenda
against Alex kurtzman but I've been a
bit up and down with some of this new
track
I've liked bits I've disliked other bits
Starfall Academy though will follow on
from Discovery so we're gonna get to see
the Federation getting rebuilt we're
going to get to see a new Starfleet
Academy we're going to get to see some
brand new starships and I am a sucker
for a brand new starship
but that might be about the end of the
positives because we're also going to
get to see a bunch of 16 somethings
going through Starfleet Academy I'm not
sure where are we going to get the
action from I'm not sure where we're
going to get much of the entertainment
from and the people out there that shout
woke everything I fear they're going to
get some opportunities to shout it again
because what we're going to get to see
is a bunch of species trying to work
together at Starfleet Academy that
haven't worked together for a very long
time Generations in fact now this is
going to be a bit like Enterprise where
a lot of the species that ended up being
part of the Federation didn't get on
that well at first I'm assuming we're
going to see a bit of that again and I'm
afraid this is going to be a metaphor
for things like race
but
Star Trek is it is best when it's doing
things like that isn't it Star Trek is
is best when it is challenging the
problems within our society so again
maybe that will be a positive
I suspect it won't be then I suspect it
will actually be boring but we'll have
to wait and see because any idea however
stupid if done well could still work
um I'm willing to give staff the academy
a chance I'm just very honest about my
reservations going forwards so there's
another reason though why Starfleet
Academy has been given the green light
that Discovery actually had quite a
young demographic that it actually did
have quite a good audience and that
audience was younger that even though
that show between trekkies is quite
unpopular and I'm afraid it is
but actually the audience is pretty good
and that Paramount want to keep that
younger audience so now they're
tailoring a TV show just for them a TV
show with a far younger audience a far
more exciting for a younger audience
cast and stories may be tailored again
for them
I really think that this is quite
possibly what is happening here I'm not
sure that this show is actually for
trekkies or definitely not the older
trekkies like me our show is Picard
season three our show will maybe be
something else maybe section 31 maybe
something else that maybe Terry mattalis
will do that actually this show is for
that younger demographic and that maybe
Paramount are just trying to create a
show for each of the different
demographics that they see Prodigy is a
kid show lower decks is a comedy show
strangely worlds is maybe a little bit
more for the trekkies and this new
Starfleet Academy will be the younger
new trackies I'm just hoping though that
actually at the end of Picard season
three we do get a new series that series
is potentially run by Terry metallis
because he did such a good job with
Picard season three maybe a show that
could follow on from Picard season three
now what would we call such a show oh
yes dark Trek Legacy that actually
metallis has already talked about follow
on aboard the Titan captain seven of
nine it's easy just do that maybe that
is the show that will be for us
so
I'm wondering if that is the plan it
feels very much like an executive's
management type of plan to me let's have
as many different Star Treks as possible
we'll make them all different that way
we get to appeal to a wider audience now
there'll be a lot of people that will
watch all of it and just go I just love
Star Trek regardless I'm once
fortunately not one of those people for
me a show has to speak to me it has to
be something I enjoy for to me to watch
it I'm not just going to watch something
just because they put Star Trek or Star
Wars or something like that at the start
of the title sequence
there has been a fair bit of trouble in
the Star Trek house but strange new
worlds and Picard season 3 have been
brilliant and have maybe put out a few
of the fires that were at risk of
Burning Down The Star Trek house
I think Starfleet Academy has a lot to
thank Picard season 3-4 but I did a poll
because I wondered what you thought this
is not just about me and I basically
said Starfleet Academy is this a big
backward step for Star Trek yes it is or
no any new Star Trek is brilliant well
after 1100 votes 77 percent of you
thought that this announcement actually
was a huge backward step for Star Trek
that we were hopeful that we were moving
away from Discovery and some of the very
poor mistakes that were made
particularly in the first couple of
seasons of it and that we were moving
towards a brighter future and maybe a
Terry metallis future where actually we
were going to get to see some of the
Star Trek like strange new worlds and
Picard season three more
well it turns out we're not so this is
going to be showrun by kurdsmen in
cooperation with somebody else so as
long as that other person is a massive
Trekkie right that will save the day
unfortunately the other person is no
gonna land out she's most famous for
show running Nancy Drew but guys I would
love to know what you think so get into
the comments is this show something you
actually think could be good if done
right at the end of the day that's true
for any show right or actually is this
one doomed to fail and do you think the
people that do shout woke are going to
be screaming it at this
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you're thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our newest
videos also you can check out the
description there's loads of related
Sidetrack stuff including Facebook link
Discord server where people go and have
a nice chat and things like our Twitter
account
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month you can get to
see them first and without the adverts
it also really helps the channel
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
[Music]